hey youtubers is charlie because dr. who
is coming back really soon and so many
of you guys found me because of
something else I wanted to do a video
for everyone who has never seen it
before just explaining where to start
and why it is the most fun hour you will
ever spend watching TV I'm also starting
my weekly doctor who give away all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video but
i'll be listing all the episodes that
you should start with as well as some
suggestions for other things for Peter
Capaldi who's going to be the new actor
playing the doctor and just to clarify
the giveaway is basically just like a
twenty-dollar amazon gift card if your
international it's paypal so it's really
simple so right now people are calling
guardians of the galaxy the most fun
Marvel movie ever well think of doctor
who is being like the most fun science
fiction ever so most important stuff
first episode 1 of series 8 that's the
new season is going to air on august
twenty-third that's a saturday on august
25th you can actually go into cinemas
all over the world and see it on like
the big screen so i'll have information
about that in the description so the
reason this new series is such a big
deal is because it's a brand new actor
playing the doctor Peter Capaldi meaning
that the show is going to go in a
completely new direction each new actor
that takes on the role honors previous
doctors with catchphrases affectations
or clothes they wear it just added 50th
anniversary last year so there's a
pretty deep well of character traits to
draw from but each new actor kind of
brings something new to the role so if
you've never seen Peter Capaldi before
I'll have some suggestions for other
stuff of his to watch one of the really
special things about being part of the
Doctor Who fandom is that it exists in
this special territory the special
pantheon of fandoms like talking and
star wars whereby you know you have
really old material so you have really
old fans and really new fans that are
just discovering for the first time it's
also one of the reasons why no one can
agree which doctor is the best just
because everyone started at a different
point everyone has their own doctor that
introduced them to the series and
another big thing that sets Doctor Who
apart from other science fiction series
or other genre series in general is that
unlike say Game of Thrones which takes
its universe very seriously doctor who
will do fantasy stories it'll do horror
stories it'll do drama it'll do
relationship comedy like during matt
smith's run it does all different things
like you can go from hard sci-fi with a
story like the doctor traveling to the
end of time or traveling outside normal
space to interact with creatures the
size of asteroids but there was this one
episode back when Matt Smith was still a
doctor where there were two Harry Potter
actors and dinosaurs on a spaceship and
unless you are made of stone you ended
up crying when one of those dinosaurs
died at the end of the episode it's
really strange some of the genres that
it jumps around but that's what makes it
so much fun one of the biggest tag lines
is all of time and space where do you
want to go like there are no limits on
what kind of stories that it can do
because it's become such a big part of
the culture in the UK and in the last 10
to 20 years all over the rest of the
world it's a big watermark for famous
actors to guest star on the show like I
just mentioned the two harry potter
actors those were actually mark williams
who was Arthur Weasley and David Bradley
who was argus filch he also plays Walder
Frey on Game of Thrones it's not
something you think about all the time
but a good way to think about the show
is crossing the fandom streams like
doctor who does stories that cross a lot
of different fandoms so for anyone who's
brand new to the series or who hasn't
watched Doctor Who for a while Peter
Capaldi is going to be the most
important thing about this new run his
doctor who episodes will be completely
different from Matt Smith's doctor who
episodes whatever matt smith was doctor
there was a lot of a relationship comedy
going on just because he was so young
and a lot of the companions were very
attractive but Peter Capaldi is one of
the oldest actors to play the role so
obviously they're not going to be doing
that during his run supposedly now the
show is going to look more like classic
horror sci-fi whenever I say things like
that in my head I'm thinking like
classic Sigourney Weaver alien like that
first alien movie but think of it more
is like Jack the Ripper with time travel
really you can expect lots of different
types of genres lots of different scary
stories crossing different genres
tagline for the first big trailer for
this new series was Doctor Who into
darkness which for me was probably the
most exciting thing the BBC could have
put in that trailer it just sounds so
awesome so the next big thing about
Doctor Who is the rotating cast of
companions and secondary characters
companions are people who travel with
the doctor full time they're usually
only a couple of them around at any one
time and right now Clara Oswald is the
only one play by jenna-louise Coleman
but supposedly we're actually going to
meet a few new ones after the first few
episodes in series 8 the secondary
characters and the villains are usually
where you see those really famous
British actors show up when they cast
someone who's real
well known or who's already a really
established actor usually they get a
really amazing character to play but
they don't stick around for a long time
Peter Capaldi the person who's playing
the new doctor was actually a big guest
star when David Tennant was playing the
doctor that was before Matt Smith it's a
pretty big easter egg for the fandom and
now everyone's wondering if Capaldi's
earlier character on the show will have
anything to do with the story this year
most people probably know Peter Capaldi
from in the thick of it Capaldi plays
this character called Malcolm Tucker and
he has the most foul mouth you have ever
heard it's hilarious if you do search
for him on tumblr it's all gifs of him
dropping f-bombs it's so great next if
you really want to catch up on Peter
Capaldi Torchwood children of the earth
is really good to watch Capaldi plays
another morally ambiguous person of
authority who's forced to do some really
awful things in the name of survival
this is also on hulu it's Torchwood
season 3 basically but it's only
available on Hulu Plus and it's also
available on Netflix then you could
watch his episode of Doctor Who he was
on during series 4 episode 2 it's called
the fires of Pompeii it's only available
on Hulu Plus and Netflix too but it also
starts Karen Gillan in a different role
before she became a full-time campaign
during matt smith's run he's actually in
full body makeup just like she is during
guardians of the galaxy she plays nebula
in that movie so here's an episode guide
for which episodes to watch if you've
never watched Doctor Who before or if
you just want to reboot your brain
before series eight starts every time a
new doctor comes on there look at about
explain the basics so don't worry if
you've never watched Doctor Who before
this is going to be really easy to jump
on so I'll have links to all this stuff
in the description too but for an
introduction to the show's core concepts
like regeneration and time travel from
series one there's episode to the end of
the world episode 9 and 10 empty child
and the doctor dances episodes 11 and 12
bad wolf and parting of ways so that's
like the bare minimum just the basics
then if you get through that and you
want to watch a little bit more move on
to series 2 there's series two Episode
two school reunion episodes five and six
rise of the Cybermen an age of Steel
then there's series 3 episode 10 blink
hello weeping angels and then there's
the TV special the end of time so you
can learn all about the master then
moving on series 5 episode
10 Vincent in the doctor one of the
finest episodes of Doctor Who ever then
there's the 2012 christmas special the
snowmen and then to learn all about the
current companion Clara all the episodes
from series 7 part 2 after you watch all
that you're basically current with the
show but there are a few specials that
are a little more advanced and deal with
some of the other doctors essentially
it's all the specials surrounding the
50th anniversary and Matt Smith's
regeneration there's the night of the
doctor that's actually free on YouTube
I'll link for that in the description to
the day of the doctor and then the time
of the doctor that's Matt Smith's
regeneration in 2 Peter Capaldi those
two episodes are only on amazon so you
do have to pay for them to watch them
but i'm sure the BBC and BBC america
will replay them so that's a pretty long
list that should keep you pretty busy
until series 8 gets here again there's a
link in the description with specific
links to each of those episodes on
netflix and hulu and if you just want
the basics just watch the episodes from
series 1 but here's the details on the
videos that i'm going to be doing
because you know part of the fun of
doctor who is looking for Easter eggs
and references to old episodes so
whenever I start posting episode videos
i'll have like a bonus video i'll post
first which will explain like a core
concept that's dealt with in each
episode and then i'll have my episode
review and then i'll have a Q&A video or
we'll just dive deeper into the biggest
questions that you guys have and if
there's ever anything that you guys want
to spend more time talking about just
let me know in the comments and we'll
just focus on that stuff right now there
are a couple legal places where you can
watch Doctor Who every week there's BBC
one in the UK and people in America
watched on BBC America then in Canada
there's sky 1 i'm not completely sure
where all the international territories
aired on but if you've ever watched
Doctor Who before just watch it on the
same channel or if you're not sure just
check your local listings and if you do
live in a country where they do not air
Doctor Who and you use streaming to
watch your TV shows just continue to do
that I am so excited you guys have no
idea this is going to be such a fun
series I know it's supposed to be scary
you know classic or but it's gonna be so
much fun I actually just quit my job if
you guys didn't see the video i posted a
while ago but I timed it so that my last
day was like the week before doctor who
came back just so that I would have some
time to get ready because I have to move
to a new apartment doctor who was
actually the first video I did on my
channel whenever I started that was for
the 2012 Christmas special please do not
watch it it is super embarrassed
it's a terrible video I like to think
that I got a little bit better at making
videos since then but why you guys are
getting ready and watching some of those
episodes that I listed click here to get
my breakdown of the latest trailer and
click here to learn about some of the
new characters that are coming thank you
so much for watching you guys have no
idea how much fun doctor who's going to
be this year I'll see you tomorrow high
fives
you